[Musique]
en signant le pacte de solidarité
territoriale avec la commune de
sainte-marie le département s'engage à
financer à hauteur de trois millions
sept cent mille euros
les projets d'investissement et les
actions sociales sur ce territoire en
faveur de la population
une véritable bouffée d'oxygène prochain
à paris étant donné que les budgets
qu'ils soient contraints aujourd'hui
avec les robinets qui se ferment les
partout avec les coups de rabot haut
niveau
gouvernementale mais à certaines
n'arrivent l'a pas nommé et ça va nous
aider justement après au niveau de ses
investissements qu'on a à faire au
niveau du réseau routier au niveau de
l'eau est enrichie pour qu'on soit la
nouvelle nouvelle 630 mille euros seront
consacrés uniquement aux actions
sociales pour les publics vulnérables
un travail cohérent la commune et le
département oeuvre pour la population
comme ici sur ce site où le département
a mis le terrain disposition de la
mairie qui a réalisé des aménagements
désormais une association de quartier
créé du lien social sur cet espace
partagé à la rivière des pluies et les
habitants se sont impliqués dans le
jardin légumes fleurs est ici font des
activités aussi ils font des activités
avec les grands parents c'est aussi du
lien entre les gramounes et les enfants
tu n'es intergénérationnel et là ils
m'ont bien expliqué qu'il faut mettre en
place du soutien scolaire pour les
marmailles de ce chantier ma c'est ça
que je trouve formidable c'est cette
envie de travailler ensemble qui a
permis de réaliser cet équipement
le président le maire et les conseillers
départementaux de la commune se sont
ensuite rendus sur ce chantier de
construction de la future maison
d'assistants maternels d'une capacité
d'accueil de 25 enfants
[Musique]